jill just received forty dollars the
number of dollars she has left y after x
days is approximated by the formula y is
equal to forty minus two point five x
graph the equation and use the graph to
estimate how much money jill will have
eight days later so let's just make a
table of x and y values then we can use
that table to actually plot the graph
and then ask us to do everything else
they want us how much money she'll have
after eight days we can actually just
put that right in the equation we might
as well do that
so we're doing numbers of days we're not
going to go back in time she starts with
forty dollars so we can start with zero
days so zero days so she just receives
forty dollars you have to look at the
equation here what's zero days after
that how much money will she have well
she hasn't had a chance to spend it yet
so you could just think about it she'll
have forty dollars or you could look at
the equation and see that the equation
verifies this when x is zero so the y
value is going to be 40
minus 2.5
times 0 which is just 40
because that part right over there is 0.
so at time at 0 number of days she will
have 40 dollars now let's do we could do
one day later but then we're going to
have these decimal points in here so we
always so that this part of the equation
always ends up with clean numbers let's
multiply it by multiples of two
so then at two days
after two days what how much money will
she have was going to be 40
minus two times or i'll do the same
order minus two point five times two two
point five times two is five so forty
minus five is thirty five dollars
after four days it's going to be 40 let
me do this in a different color so when
i plot the points you see where i got my
information from
after four days she's going to have 40
minus 2.5 times 4.
2.5 times 4 is 10 so 40 minus 10 is 30.
you see every two days that goes by she
is spending five dollars five dollars
every two days or two and a half dollars
every day and you actually see that
right over here she is spending that's a
negative sign two and a half dollars
every day
every time you increment x by one two
and a half dollars goes away let's keep
going so then after
look for another color here
after six days it's going to be 40 minus
2.5 times 6
2.5 times 6 is 15 40 minus 15 is equal
to 25
then finally we can do after eight days
after eight days it is 40. she'll have
40 minus 2.5
times 8 2.5 times 8 is 20 so 40 minus 20
is 20
so we actually answered her question our
estimate for how much money jill will
have eight days later is actually 20 but
let's do the first part let's actually
graph the equation see it visually so
let me draw some axes here this will be
a hand-drawn graph but i think it'll get
the job done
so let's make that our y-axis or in this
case it's the number of dollars she has
and let's make this
my x-axis
this is our x-axis and we only need to
focus on the first quadrant because at
least in this context she won't have
we're assuming she won't have a negative
number of dollars so the y-values will
be positive and we assume that the days
are only going to be positive we're not
going to deal with negative time so the
x values are going to be positive so
we're only going to be operating in the
first quadrant so that's all i have to
draw and so she starts off at 40 dollars
so let me let me mark off the y-axis let
me mark it off in increments of 10 first
so this would be
ten dollars this would be twenty
this would be thirty
this would be forty dollars
and then i could do the
the thirty five the twenty five the
fifteen and then the five and then let
me mark off the days
so this is let me do it i'll do that
same yellow color so this is after
this is after two days this is four days
this is six days this is eight days we
could keep going if we like so after two
days she after sorry after zero day so
this right over here after zero days she
has forty dollars so that's this point
right over here that's that right over
there then after two days she has 35
dollars after two days she has 35
dollars
2 in the x direction then we go up 35 so
that's that point right over there then
after four days she has 30 dollars four
days 30 dollars you go x4 remember the
days are in x
or x are the days actually your market
these are days
and these the y axis is the dollar axis
so after four days she has thirty
dollars after four days she has thirty
dollars then after six days i'll do the
same color after six days she has 25
dollars so x
x coordinate is six y coordinate is 25
and then finally after eight days she
has twenty dollars eight days twenty
dollars
eight she has twenty dollars
and so we plotted those points we could
connect them we could actually just if
we had a nice ruler we could just
connect two of those and we would have
the line but our line looks something
let me do this in a new color our line
would look something like
our line would look something like that
that shows how much she has after every
day and we're done we've graphed the
equation we know she'll have twenty
dollars left after eight days